Snapchat is bigger than Twitter.
According to a report by Bloomberg, Snapchat has 150 million daily users.
Twitter has an estimated 140 million people using the service daily.
That Twitter number was figured out from Twitter's official monthly metric...
...of 310 million active users.
Neither company confirmed their daily user numbers.
If these figures are accurate that's bad news for Twitter...
...as the service has been struggling to compete in the social media space.
Twitter's been around for ten years...
...while Snapchat has been around for only four years.
Twitter CEO, Jack Dorsey spoke at the Code Conference this week...
...and said he finds Snapchat very modern and applauded its interface.
Dorsey even described Twitter as confusing.